HAALLOOO
Konichiwa everybody
Today we're playing Scorn
A horror game :D (oh wow another horror game)
Although you Amnesia jumpscare loving freaks
might be a lil disappointed
This one has a different approach to horror
being a lil bit more subtle
I'm super excited for this game
It was launched as a kickstarter
and uh
I helped fund it
Yay for me !! 👏👏
Supporting developers 👏👏
Yes, I am a saint 👏👏👏 ( Saint pewds)
Thank you very much !! 👏👏
The trailer for this game
is so good
I really hope
the gameplay lives up to the trailer
*eerie music plays*
It's just so....
disturbing.
In every single way
Ah it remind me 2 artists
Which I can't pronounce the name of eehhh.....
Anyone of them
Zdzisław Beksiński
and H.R Giger, of course
Enough of this aaahh... all this bullshit
Let's ..... let's play the game
Is it good?
Put on some headphones
Turn off the light,
and put it...
put it on full screen baby
cuz here we go
Of course, I used my compass...
thingy...
To go through here
wow
this place looks lovely...
surprisingly a Serbian developer
and the game it, says supposedly to be released
October...
next year.
Where do we go straight? Left? Right?
deummm....
All the options looks equally horrible...
let's go right
you know what...
I bet no ones going right
IS that a tentacle?
Thank you
Also drawing inspite...
inspiration from japanese hentai, this game
How great!
Ohh wow look at that!
Ohhh it get worse..
Isn't that great
uhhh...
eaahhkkkk...
Yuck
Whoa, what am I?
How do I look like?
UUHH !!
EWW !!
EEEEEEEWWWWWWWWWWWWW!!!!!!!!
DISGUSTING!!!
Let's show the compass...
Whoa, wait I have a gun???
Ohhh hell yeah
I didn't realize
there no uh
real, uh, user interface...
Sorry, what did I just do?
EWWW!!
I'm holding down Q
Eww is that a little dog??
wtf is that??
ok,
let's not hold down Q
let's go back
you know what screw that, h--place
Stupid
Now i'm scared of pressing buttons on my keyboard
Ok, well going right was clearly the wrong option
That's OK (x1)
That's OK (x2)
Then we'll go straight, from now on..
Ohh this is a compass door
Hello Mr. Compass Door
There you go, let me show you my amulet....
oh god
This really actually does reminds me of Amnesia
Just cuz, fear of the unknown
I've never played a horror game like this
So I don't know what the heck is gonna happp--
ooohh...what the...
I can't use it?
What if i show you...?
It's look like I need to stick my hand in there..
Maybe I'm missing something...
It's giving me a big red bar so...
it looks like...
ugh, can't go there either
ok...
disgusting by the way
hhaaa.... just a mix of like...
awful alien things and....
human flesh?
Is just
like, sooo nasty to me man....
I really feel...
oh this...
I'm... i need to learn how to play this game
We have, uh, exhausted all of our options...
So Please(Help Me)
Let there be something great down here (such as....)
something aaaa...
A nice...
Cup of soup perhaps
ooh, look at that
aoohh...there's no soup here
A different kind of soup
Great.
this looks fantastic!!!
EEEWWW!!!
WHAT A
OOAAORA UGH
Yucky Yuck
uueehh...
as a great man once said
it was me
EEEEEWWW!!!!
No.
Nope.
It is coming here?
AHH!! WHAT THE!!!
HOW?!!
OOH ITS FAST!!
OHH! I can't see any--nothing...
Wow, I just got rekt dude
Here I come......
It's Me.... (mario!)
ok, you son of a bitch
Kay
Alright....
I'm ready
I have trained in the art of combatry
You ugly son of a mop
It's not working
AHH IT...!!!
OHH !! J--
SHIT!!!
Ah I need to reload
I got one more, prob--
Ey
EY
NO
EEEWWW!!
EEWWWWWW!!!
Can we not?!
Let me just...
EWWWW!!
ohh fuck..
asshole...
uuuhhhh....
aahhh....
DISGUSTING.....
Does that not freak you out...?
that...putting those things in??
excuse me
amulet door
I believe I have an amulet
You know what
I don't wanna go there anyway
EEEEWWWWW!!!!!
EWW!! EWW!! EWW!! EWW!! EEEWWWW!!!
UH..
Oh My...
EW!
Wait, this is open now
Oohhh Noo
Uuuaahh...
It's another one of these
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, no, no, no
it's here
Now we can use the...
The Hand Thing
Ahh...
Uuuaaahhh...
I'm moving it over there...
it like an On & Off switch
Soo detailed...
OOHH NOOO....
eu heh heh...
it the door open now ?
I think i did something
oohhh I need to press my amulet there
of course....
ohh.. i see so i upgrade it.....
oh...my god
ok, i see it now
my space fidget spinner has been improved
Thank you everybody
i will grab that now...
Ohh lovely
it's blue now
So now we can open BLUE DOORS
Excellent
Just what I wanted
more....
spooky dooky
Hi Mr. Blue Door
thank you
okay
doing pretty good
easy
oh, its a space elevator
ohhhh
ohhh noo
shit
I shouldn't have done that
pressed the button
please don't tell me
I have to redo everything
I gotta redo everything huh
you know what
there was plenty of blue doors
from before
I don't need that blue door
ahahaha
thank you
very much
I do recall there being a blue door
actu--actually
blue door here
much better
blue door
look at that
thank you
don't insta kill me
alright who wants some
oh god
okay
alright
GOT HIM
WOOO
AHHHH
EHHHH
Sorry space cow
dog thing
baby
sorry
sumimasen
okay
You have to die
for the great...greater good
of tentacle hentai
alright
oh wow
this ju...this ju
just looks great
this just... just looks great!
I love the place!
The wallpapers, great
Don't kill me
I'm just gonna press this button
Oh look at that!
giant
gigantesco elevator
per pewdiepiedo
*GASP*
is that where we were
in the beginning?
I think it is (x1)
I think it is (x2)
that looks great
and then we can walk
Hiiii
no
don't shoot me
listen
*evil laughter*
okay
I'm sorry
AH JA BLA--
Kill it!
Oh god
there's more
okay, kay, kay
oh there's two more
fuck
stay away
space baby
head shot
you need to head shot him pewds
WOOO
THAT'S RIGHT
No there's more
there's more
reload
ay no take your time
putting in those reverse pimples man
alright alright
alright
space dog
we're good
gucci
shut up
my god
STOP
space pimple
return
shh--quiet
quiet you
I'm--I'll be there
I'll be there...
those fuckers are gonna fall down
you don't think
I don't think
that you not gonna
Don't
touch me
okay?
don't
touch me
space...monkey baby
baby
space
What do you want?
look how many there are!
oh they fly (they believe they can flyyyy they believe they can touch the skyyy)
aw no, this is like Doom dude
i hate those flying fuckers
I'm going here now
oh god this is where we were before
isn't it?
yeah okay
so that was like a shortcut?
it's a bit disorienting
but it's also kinda cool
how it connects
so where did we...
shh
what did I say?
just don't f'ing listen
no
did they see me?
one of them must have
go
fuck
I hate them
behind me
ughhhh
reload it
I--I'm out of ammo
How much do I have?
3 bullets
damn
this is intense man
fuck
alright
we're gonna have to make every bullet count at this point
okay, we're fine
he went away
whew
alright
yes!
let's go
show em the amulet pewds
there ya go
bye bye!
ohhh...
what is this?
Eh?
oh dude, I do not...
I do not have enough ammo for this
that was it
is he dead?
he's not dead yet
fuck
where do I get ammo?
shit
Nooooo
I'm not dead
I'm dead
Nooooo
it's cool
cuz we know the shortcut
everybody
be quiet
thank you
so lame
you guys are so lame
Look he's doing...
*laughs*
Oh WOW...
he's, he's a...
blender, everybody
it's a space blender
how could I have been so scared by
those space blenders
I don't know
I guess
Ehehe, you get weird
aw shit, I forgot
It's fine--
Oh yeah, this one fucks off
BWAH
SUCK IT
SPACE BABIES
Christian channel!!
Not today
cuz pewdiepie has
more pimples
thank you
I can't believe I died there
oh my god
really?
I died at the end
great.
*laughs*
well there you go
at least I can say that I've played it
to its fullest
okay
that was scorn
what did you think?
I'm very excited for the full version
I think finally
finally a horror game
doing something a little bit different
my god did it have the atmosphere
I was genuinely freaked out playing it
and I think, probably, you were watching it as well
so thank you for tagging along
appreciate it
and yeah
look forward to the full version
*burps*
that's it from me for now
and remember to
don't...
have space pimples
squad fam out